verpacktes nicht wir haben einen
reisebus ist halo auf mit dem zu
interagieren ich will
hallöchen freunde werkzeug bei captain
kreft die letzte folge war immens krass
ich habe er nicht diesen volkes erfolgen
gas getötet mit seinen eigenen waffen
dann sind wir ca 10.000 mal gestorben
und das war alles so krass heftig
intensiv krass einfach nur krass dieser
begriff würde für solche folgen
entwickelt das war nicht mehr normal
wieso liegt die red storm ich weiß nicht
mal schon mal schon mal schon mal was
ich in hand halte
aufbauen der bange machen wir machen ein
kleines häuschen für den ok war richtig
und ich hab eine feuerkugel die ihr
kommt man die wertvollen tue ich packe
mal alles leben in die wertvoll alter
wir brauchen mehr hat vollen truhe
jaja oder wir müssten die alte autos
stecken spitzhacke sind nicht wirklich
wertvoll
komme was du von gott niemals alt vor da
ich mich vielleicht auch die karotten
lauch karotten einfach an pflanzen ja
auf jeden fall
wie pflanzt man hat ja dann ist nur
wurden auch irgendwo irgendwo muss
satire sind kartoffeln lkw
damit haben wir schon mal wir haben ganz
viele karten jetzt paar die beiden
scheine womit denn mit krawatten erwarte
ich mach doch schnell neue hier das feld
richtig damit ich noch mal ein paar mehr
ohne momentum da ist das ding genau so
wir müssen vielleicht dann auch mal
alter wir mittlerweile gar keinen hunger
problem mehr richtig gut wie diese
ganzen lässt entwickelt hat wirklich das
ist ein traum
ja nur mit den hühnern ihr da die sind
ja so crazy müssen so dass ich hier im
kessel
das muss auf jeden fall da bleiben das
ist der neue test anderes ist das ist
kein rassist rassist ketzler man aber
wir haben schon wieder 26 gebratener 26
münchen die werden jetzt gebraten dann
haben wir eins der hühnchen alter sowohl
sind die beiden schweine jetzt schwein
kommen rüber
hallo schwein genau ich fahre jetzt mal
die schweine packen einfach alles für
die umwelt in die kiste links das nicht
mehr erst mal konnte überzeugen für die
schweine ahnung junge macht um eine
folge ich ganz fest dass ich noch machen
wir sind nur hören
ja ich habe gehört ich auch so am ende
meine sache nie wieder so ein bisschen
sortiert ich habe immer auf totales
chaos
dass der boden so da brauche ich noch
sondern nehme ich mal die noch mit äxten
da und da spur einer und sonstwie so
liegt er die eisenbahn und die ender
perlen in der komme immer auf gomez
ich sortiere immer richtig immer haben
wir noch holz für die kiste oder so aber
wir haben sogar noch eine kiste auch gut
und tasci hat einfach noch einmal
gewählt ich habe diesen block machte
manchmal legen die neidern dessen macht
das richtig klopp nein mach dich auf
gibt immer wie viele eier da drin sind
und haben wir doch irgendwie holz für
ihre fahrzeuge
wir haben sogar noch zu einer gegend wo
echte könnten vielleicht mal so einen
vorraum machen will
hast du die münchner die hühner schweine
ja noch nicht ich möchte erstmal hier
mit einem zaun entweder weil sie viel
essen wir einfach haben
das kann doch nicht wahr sein
jetzt ist das schon wieder so ein
münchen so warte mal schnell mal den
baum hierfür passende axt nehmen
ja ich habe ja in nierstein axt erreicht
auch er hier warmmiete eigentlich zahl
auf den punkt erwartet dass da oben dass
da hinten mal was will ich einmal einen
wollten coolen neuen weg von unserer
höhle hier die mitbewohner links ja aber
von hier zu dem dings zu den hühnern
habe ich mir mal so gedacht dass wir
hier über in die hühnerfarm reihen
können
warte ich habe mich schon eine coole
idee neuer torwart blog abgewaschen
bisschen abgebrochen und so auch
irgendwie überdachten also auf jeden
fall die vom dorfbewohner müssen um von
einer kuh weil wänden gast mal wieder
angreift ich wäre dafür dass wir das
alles hier mal überdacht
weißt du wer stimmt eigentlich voll gut
ich brauche es jetzt mal ganz kurz hier
in den hühnerstall ein braun leiter name
leitern wir haben wir gut gemacht
und wo sind die karotten karotten habe
ich mit inventar mache ich aber direkt
was ich mache gerade das gehege 14 54 56
wie macht man doch mal ein zaun tor
kopiert und tollen weg rein und die
können nicht durch weil leitern sind
weiß er
ach so aber die können doch leitern
klettern nicht so die können da nicht
rein
da geht keiner rein hochreiter könnte es
aber nicht in diesem kleinen abstand
weiter ok kannst du mir den türchen
machen für du musst links zwei stocker
rechts zwei städte zwei holz barren
also ich hab schon ok hab ich's lieber
junge darf ich mal ein paar hühner töten
wir brauchen eigentlich zu essen aber
obwohl nie kommt dass keines töten lasse
einfach nein nein nein
das schweizer paar schweine ich noch nie
gemacht habe
junge wie viele münchen alter das aber
normal hier braucht ihr nicht die band
hier können dazwischen sogar schon tor
junge diese hühnchen braten hier immer
noch und da kommen immer noch neue cl
da ist ein schwein gibt mir die karotten
da kann ich schon mal die schweizer
paaren nein eben nicht weil das soll
auch hier drinnen passieren kannst du
sofort machen und zwar jetzt kommt
schweinchen möchtest du es machen kannst
du auch gerne machen ja gehen wir die
sache wohl die alle erst mal den
käfigreihen und dann auch hühnchen die
komplexen ist vergeblich das geht ja gar
nicht die kompanie mit die scheine
euro sie sind dann nicht gewöhnt hatte
ich von craft werde ich das irgendwie
gleich ein stirbt oder so das doch auch
das wichtigste guck mal wenn man babys
schon vor dem hühner fieber ihr vor wie
schwein
ihr habt da doch eine april dann noch
einen redstone etwas was ich jetzt
nämlich meinte was wir machen könnten
wäre genau könnte man hier auszumachen
bei da kann man doch der kommt nicht
durch aber keine kugeln also wenn meint
wenn wir beschlossen werden wir könnten
uns auch einfach mit mit cobblestone
machen aber es war hässlich dann lass
doch lieber mit steinen er wird mit ca
mit zäunen ja wenn man die doch
nebeneinander macht ja aber dafür
brauchen wir so viel holz und vor allem
will können durch zäune wenn die wände
diese in dem vier quadraten anders
können auch max durchfallen
ich möchte immer noch ausleuchtet die
haben auch sand für glas ist gerade so
vor dem einfach nie wieder tag einfach
immer hier ja wir haben immer tag an dem
kein tag e mail ja wir können aber er
alles ausleuchten lassen
okay okay ich war das einfach mal auf
diese höhe dann können auch bäume
wachsen ist doch eine karotte diesen
allen der essence kiste so siehst du
dass wir das hier dann so secker zu
bauen
ja und ich weise sie kommen sie kommen
sie kommen die schweine kommt rein
jetzt geht es mit dem karten ja super
ich glaube die kommen nicht durch diese
tür durch du musst die tür erst einmal
abbauen als baby schaaf ist drin
endlich scheint das ist aber auch
kleiner länder kommt auch gleich schon
wieder eine kiste noch ein erfolg dann
haben wir hinten die kiste und oben die
kiste ja wir wollen wir noch ein erfolg
um dann wenn man es auch für eventuelle
wir müssen unbedingt ein sattel finden
müssen unbedingten sattel finden wenn
wir dieses zuckerrohr haben können wir
auch so viele neue sachen machen dann
waren wir einfach das zuckerrohr an
aber so eine sicher und alles mögliche
alter bub nur noch folge stress verfolge
ich bin auch noch völlig fertig ich war
nicht mehr normal
es war gar nicht normal aber du hast den
erfolg ich habe den erfolg das
wichtigste so viel zeit sind auch schon
wieder
wir haben echt gar kein echtes problem
mehr
ja was wir am anfang voll stark hatten
ja am anfang war es echt krass lassen
unsere ganze holz werkzeuge bitte
einfach wegschmeißen ihm so viel platz
weg nicht vor luca ich will einfach mal
was ein rätsel
hast du noch cobblestone nee nee nee wir
brauchen wir ja noch was für die ab
dienstag
da oben ich mache jetzt erstmalig wohl
cobblestone für den elbe cobblestone für
den bereich von villiger für den bereich
brauchen wir auch was haben die
schallplatte
wir können wir nachher musikspielen 30
ich mache schon mal unsere ganzen
goldnuggets zu goldbarren nägel wie geht
das also komplett ausfüllen ja leider
man so viel bringt das nicht alter wir
sind kirche und in der höhle da wo die
du meinst tochter können die gar nicht
durch die hühnchen
dadurch können und auch die großküchen
also david tricks die gehen nicht da
machen wir uns an der sonne platte weißt
du die man soll ja sie machen
minecraft die heißt dass luke lupe
nehmen alle türen falte falsche falsche
genau so scheiße war okay ich weiß es
geht dann nehme ich mir hier eben ein
bisschen wir haben ja keine holz wir
haben gar kein holz heraus wieso er denn
gar kein holz dabei will gar kein holzer
ja genau
das klingt das denn logisch wie kann man
den kuh anlocken mit welchem rohstoff
mit bei diesem doch mit weizen stimmt
wir haben schon drei gold blöcke für den
in lodz apple hoffe dass auch einfach
mal ein schnee was wollen wir damit dem
schnee eigentlich machen war da in wien
sondern links drauf spawn sind schnee
man kann auch nicht passt die andere
christentum und dann können wir uns ja
vielleicht unser bio dadurch irgendwie
ändern so eine art schnee bewahre ich
dachte schon längst gestorben
nur die welt ihre uralte was gemacht
guck mal hier mal die kuh eingesperrt
unsere wertvollste stirbt habe ich alles
überdacht eigentlich dürfte ja nicht
stemmen jetzt kommt der dorfbewohner
kannst du gerne zu sehen ich möchte ins
bonn
vergiss nicht was ist eigentlich mit dem
zu interagieren ich will nur scheiße
bohlens 40 forte das fleisch haben keine
hungerproblem sitzt beweise blöde insel
diese psychiatrie wo jeder geräusche
macht auch vor der insel eigentlich ja
da ich nenne das hier insel wenn wir
hier nicht weiter weg kommen insel der
villa zur ist ein gefängnis ein erstes
stück land oder eingegrenzte stechen mit
einem psychologen alter okay das heißt
wir versuchen was für ein erfolg werden
machen alter vielleicht brauchen weil es
praktisch keine ahnung wofür man sie
braucht kann mit dem village irgendwie
handeln weil sonst wird er unter ihnen
natürlich kann man mit dem hannah ja
aber ob das ein erfolg bringt ich komme
ganz kurz hier raus und ich glaube ich
nicht
das ende findet das ende
wir haben doch ende augen aber wir
können doch unten noch nicht in den raum
rein und braucht dafür stimmt und müssen
cent stimmt stimmt
man man man ja gut egal ich würde sagen
versuchen in paris zwei kühe mit weit
verdammtes jahren nur eine kuh heißt wir
haben ja schon mal vermehrt wo sind die
dm bestimmt hat er schon lächeln die
kommentare geschrieben
fliege auf einem schwein die kripo unter
geräumte in sattel
gibt's doch nicht klaus schulze bat
freilegen mit einer lore mindestens
einen kilometer an einem stück zurück
bald können wir erst es bald diesen
blöden kuchen machen das mit läge mit
einer lore mindestens ein kilometer
zurück da hatten wir eine geschriebene
kommentar das geht nicht
ja habe ich auch gelesen fangen und
bratfisch das können wir machen am lange
aber kann man ja machen aus fäden und
sticks wir haben keinen holz ich hab
holz holz eben auch mal angel schnell
ich habe das rezept hier offen und auch
nur zwei fäden und dreist ich bin schon
dabei
da sah ich hab eine angel und jetzt muss
brauchen wir nun endlich ins
wasserbecken wat x ja hier ist ja ja ich
weiß nicht ob das damit geht wir können
ich glaube auch nicht dass das geht ich
war ich bin mir auf jeden fall sicher
ist das ziel gehen würde wenn wir noch
einmal hätten
hast du einmal sonst mache ich eben
schon ein
doch ich glaube das funktioniert hat
schon so halb einer angebissen
ich probier doch mal da kam ratsam ja
umsonst einfach hier über hier ist auf
jeden fall ja ich glaube hier geht's
auch schön in die mitte dann genau
haakon kräfte hier produktiv dabei wir
können ja auch bald oben an die truhe
machen wir dann wahrscheinlich in den
nächsten folgen
grafisch dauert moment er kam es häufig
geschieht jetzt da jetzt nicht hier
vorne ging's vollen lass mich mal
probieren aber da geht's auch 100pro
denn die andere packt sich hier mal so
hoch das ist normal dass ich noch mal
aber es geht aber nicht mehr
hundertprozentig sicher da komm ich sehe
so geplätscher um die angel rum
genau so etwas muss man mit dem fisch
machen damit braten raten nun okay dass
das geht weiter aber ich habe den erfolg
bei mir gar nicht gesehen wo wird eine
angezeigt unter unter dem ofen also
unterstellt und entwerfen
gib mir sonst mal ich probier's mal ja
ich würde das in der nächsten folge die
folgeschäden 17 minuten lang
wir sehen uns dann probiert noch mal
eben das geht nicht
ich bin hab' aber auch jetzt nein das
war schon sehr sehr knapp was weg gehen
nein die bank noch nie im leben so da
oben rum
doch auch das gehe dass ich habe gerade
erst vor ein paar tagen genauso gefischt
wie er in echt summe kommen kann als in
der nächsten folge weiter probieren ich
bin der vollen überzeugung dass das
nicht funktioniert die angepackt so
drüber über dem wasser kanal ian fisher
beißen doch 100 proben sehr gut die für
trotzdem sahen wir uns morgen wieder in
solch gefährliche feld gefallen hat dann
zeigt uns dass mit martin fischer noch
ein bisschen bei tag gehabt auf jeden
fall super bei dir ich sagte das klappt
noch und wenn ich hier 30 stunden noch
dran sitze ja gut bei mama 30 tonnen
also leute hab mal nächsten vorbeikomme
jeder 30 stunden tschüs